triple-decker hamburger made out of a
doughnut I'm going to make Steve eat one
of those no Steve's going to eat a
triple-decker hamburger at Elena all
right where where are we going Colin
we're going to the Los Angeles County
Fair ready you don't win me uh me a
prize yea excited I'm excited oh my god
I already see like nine things I want to
eat donut
cookie dough now you know we're gonna
play a little game of telephone we're
gonna go to one booth eat that amazing
food ask them what their favorite booth
is go to that booth and then we're gonna
go on and on and on and on and by the
end of this I plan to have what
everybody has at the end of a fair
sunburn and a stomachache hey our fair
share own suggesting we started chicken
Charlie's it sounds fine to me I always
get a chicken look at that booth whoa I
think we have to get a totally fried
guacamole the triple decker burger and I
think we need some fried Oreos - are we
gonna eat all that yeah yeah we're at
booth number one guys
fried blah
oh my god it's literally just wakka moly
with a layer of dough around it it's
kind of healthy right the crispness of
the fried batter is really really
important this is maybe the grossest
concoction I've ever seen and I love it
triple decker burger with Stephens
favorite Krispy Kreme donut lathe I
don't need you anymore Freddy I got this
it's sweet its savory it tastes like a
heart attack the meat and the donut are
the same texture I will say this is a
balanced meal though like we have the
meat we had the veggies and now just now
dessert I'm not mad at it wow I love it
I was expecting like too crunchy to the
Oreo but look at that they somehow made
the oriole into a soft and mushy
pleasant surprise if you were a 10 year
old which would be your favorite quite
Oreo Oreo if I was 10 I still think
fried cuacamole would be my favorite you
were way too
ten on the ten-year-old scale for sure
heart attack variable ten yeah I'm gonna
have one in like 20 minutes 11
creativity are given eight yeah
pull the score 20 out of 30 almost
perfect but we can get better if you
weren't going to eat at your booth
what other booth at the fair do you
think would be where you would get your
food I keep hearing a lot about fried
watermelon I do not know exactly the
name of the place a fair legend I like
it okay fried watermelon it is go yeah
right there yeah just covering up it's
like the Sahara out here we're on the
hunt or the booth with the fried
watermelon we don't know the name of the
booth we're just rolling with the
punches see what we stumble upon you
guys have fried watermelon
we're gonna have three six of fried
watermelon it comes gonna go should we
get pineapple PK you two watermelons one
find out the best upside-down pineapple
oh that is crazy
Tara's the queen of the deep-fried is
the deep fried watermelon
I don't even have any word wide
watermelon it's like you would think it
would melt right
no still super friend I picked this
watermelon out yesterday this is fried
pizza cheers guys tell you make pizza
uh-huh
why is it's not done more that's weird I
like it super flaky it has a taste of
the pizza and the texture of a glazed
donut if I was 10 I would love this
heart attack this is not gonna send you
to the hospital
6 creativity I give it an 8 yeah I mean
pizza fried 10 plus 6 plus 8 is 24 we're
gonna ask that where we're going next if
you're not eating at your own lovely
booth where else in the LA County Fair
do you like to eat well let's see wait
at Pepe's which is over on Tom
you ready peppe's it is let's go go you
guys are standing nails go
hi I'm Lola my number one item that I
saw I started with the fish stock with
the grilled fish tacos it's healthy
guilt free this straws for Steve I don't
want his cooties he's ready it's like
that before all over again day one guys
set the road bag this stock goes for you
Andrew
here's Colin here oh yeah it says forget
the cheese yeah the best part not fried
get out word of the fair I probably eat
here a lot we just get so tired of all
the fried food you're tired of fried
food you just have to stop eating it or
you'll die this place gave us gave me a
whole new pep in my step I was starting
to feel a little weak at one point yeah
this is a good like palate cleanser I
think our rubric should be stretched
this is our intermission because on it
on the heart-attack scale it gets a 1
and you don't need a heart attack to
have a good time we were told that the
best funnel cake at the fair right is
that the Mad Hatter funnel cake spirit
animal let's go we're gonna get ones
holy moly double-decker funnel cake we
got chocolate dipped bacon and a
double-decker funnel cake the strawberry
this is my cutie for the day what is
going on there's guys who do you know
about jacquard I know that's really
nothing I'm not a fan
maybe sophisticates
just tastes like chocolate-covered paper
funnel cake why they invented the fair
we're gonna give you a heart attack this
isn't your normal fun okay
it's so light it's not actually a heart
attack look at that crazy sweet starting
to look like a heart attack though
that's for fear
Daniel factor is this morning if you
find me a 10 year old who doesn't like
funnel cake I'll show you a very very
sad kid creativity sort of light and
feathery different yeah I'll bet they're
all guys into helmet for me nine say
visual heart attack one the news that
kid at heart attack though fried bumping
moly that was another thing this is yeah
like a sudden 26 good really good
so I'm score funnel cake we made it we
made it you made honey fair we learned
bear is a great place to go once a year
you go more than once a year
you'll be on your back I want to explode
right now actually should we get some
more fried guacamole oh yeah
we do not want maybe Hannah we have a
car right now